j'accueille ce bernard menez
sûrement beaucoup plus de google
tu m'as tu as chanté
temmar full tilt
moi j'ai du style râteau cheville âmes
annuel
le cap sur un court
tapie sur les doigts
jme couple pour toi heureusement j'ai
tout prévu en paraît quinze
sous la main
a t'on du spa sur l'eau
tu me fais chambrer
on en a parlé à retrouver bernard menez
dans le 15e arrondissement de paris
bonjour c'est toi tais toi je vous
présente tatum est un nom tu as tout
puis arrête les laisses ton assez
tranquille et c'est un chien qui est qui
est très important parce que c'est ce
chien a joué avec moi shakespeare au
théâtre national de chaillot un
compagnon de scène en somme et le petit
dernier de la famille après william
olivier elisa le quatrième enfant au 1
c'est notre quatrième enfant
en ce moment bernard revient à la
chanson et prépare un spectacle musical
des fleurs à d
est ce moi rêver
rêver des beaux jours passés sur les
tapis range quelques photos bien choisis
avec des actrices clem mois et au cours
du festival de cannes
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer donc
certains personnes certaines personnes
penelope cruz
claudia schiffer là je suis un peu
rouillée mais c'est la photo à ce pas
moi et le disque d'or qu'il a reçu pour
sa chanson jolie poupée trône également
en bonne place
[Musique]
autre corde à son arc le sport le
comédien chanteur et président d'une
équipe les polymusclés et que ça voilà
c'est reparti avec jean marais mais
voilà ma technique des dons ah oui
j'avais les cheveux ça c'est yvon leroux
qui a été parié roi de l'équipe de
france l'équipe est composée d'acteurs
et d'anciennes gloires du sport qui joue
en faveur d'associations et belmondo
dans le but est des gens très connus qui
était budget cédric et enfin thierry
rolland beaucoup de gens sont passés au
boli musclé qui on a décidé d'aider au
maximum
cause des gens différents
donc c'est notre combat c'est qu'on
essaye de faire
l'aide de proximité
d d association des gens d individus
autour du football
mais même à la pétanque et de la paix
tentent maintenant on en vient on y va
tout et arrive l'heure fatidique pour ta
toune sa promenade
alors le maître n'a plus d'yeux que pour
son chien si on croise des femelles aura
pas de problème c'est me croise des
balais peut peut-être se mettre à crier
ou à aimer c'est par essence entre
bernard menez et à thoune on se demande
qui est le plus cadeau des deux cas il a
un regard qui parle c'est très curieux
parce qu'elle a vraiment ces deux billes
dans son bep en devine ce qu'ils pensent
avec lui je me sens intelligente j'ai
l'impression de parler chien court avant
et la balade se termine toujours au
bistrot du point
le patron s'appelle bernard lui aussi
[Musique]
bernard le patron et claude et son petit
chien il ya un petit chef juste pas que
ça pas se poser de problème
vous étiez venu une fois au tchad je me
sens plus vite et religion à
suis je voulais jouer il était dans la
pièce et autres cailloux à chaillot et
il me venait saluer à la fin aussi au
lit avec une collerette élisabéthaine
c'est un bon souvenir s'appelle comment
non pas tout non non non non non non non
voilà voilà le travail
tu as fait mauvaise réputation
ce soir bernard va jouer la pièce pauvre
france dans le cadre d'un comité
d'entreprise mais avant de brûler les
planches il participe au montage du
décor l'occasion de répéter les chansons
de son futur spectacle aux côtés de
bernard sur scène xavier pour moi jouer
avec un acteur culte comme ça avec une
voix reconnaissable parmi tant de voix
nasillarde vraiment reconnaissable entre
toutes quoi pour moi c'est c'était
vraiment un rêve de gosse que je
réalisais quoi à l'affiché également
muriel montossey une ancienne élève de
la classe
j'en joue le rôle de la mère nombre de
ma femme muriel montossey et léa
françois qui joue dans plus belle la vie
et qui a pris la suite de l'uneq sens
pour l'euro de l'escort girl la salle se
remplit pendant ce temps bernard
s'échauffent
c'est l'heure du lever de rideau les
lumières de la scène la paix même loin
des théâtres des grands boulevards le
plaisir de bernard est un peu et
maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
bernard menez bernard menez bienvenue
sur le plateau de tout le monde en a
parlé
alors vous n'êtes ni le 8 août 1944 à
mailly le château dans l'yonne et
ensuite j'avais passé votre enfance à la
garenne colombes dans les hauts-de-seine
voilà père facteur mère femme au foyer
alors en 1960 vous passez votre bac et
vous entrez en classes préparatoires
tout en faisant du théâtre amateur en
parallèle pour lutter en fait contre une
timidité maladive
si une espèce de psychothérapie
inconsciente coahc ce dont je me suis
rendu compte que je pense avec le temps
sur le moment je n'y pensais pas ouais
alors en fait vous aviez deux problèmes
le premier c'est le sentiment de ne pas
intéresser les filles ce qui est pas
rare quand on est adolescent un peu
comme je dirais comme
j'avais mes idées et je n'avais pas
l'impression que mes idées intéresser
les autres et surtout que les autres et
aussi que d autres ne m'intéressait pas
trop dans l'ordre au delà quand même de
ses problèmes d'adolescent
vous aviez des interrogations plus
fondamentales et plus angoissés qu'est
ce que je suis venu faire sur cette
terre est il intéressant de vivre enfin
vous posez des questions essentielles
mais comme beaucoup d'adolescents
ouais ouais et au jour d'aujourd'hui je
pense que la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui et
peut-être même encore plus inquiète que
mon époque
alors donc vous fait maths sup maths spé
et vous présentez l'x les ponts lénine
centrale et supélec selon l'influent
quand même en fait vous n'aurez rien de
celle là non mais j'ai quand même eu un
peu plus tard l'école normale supérieure
de l'enseignement technique n'est
absolument laine 7 après un certificat
en maths et en physique alors sais c'est
pas mal un vrai quand j'ai reçu au mois
de juin les papiers à remplir pour
rentrer à 27
je m'aperçois que j'en ai pour dix ans
j'ai pris peur alors j'ai fait quelque
chose de terrible pour ma famille
d'ailleurs prouvé par an puisque j'ai
commencé par démissionner de la tête
immédiatement résilier mon sur site
d'études pour aller faire mon service
militaire pour m'en débarrasser
alors en fait au service qualité à vous
monter une troupe en était cantonné
pendant quatre mois à la caserne où on
n'avait quasiment pas sortir donc j'ai
eu envie d'utiliser ces quatre mois pas
uniquement à faire du militaire qui
combat rebelles il y avait quand même
beaucoup de gens quitter qui était doué
quitter un plutôt intello qui était
puisqu'il venait de centrales ou des
pompes des mines et on a monté sans cela
alors après le service vous cumulez des
cours d'art dramatique et l'enseignement
public le d'abord instituteur ensuite
professeur de mathématiques et de
physique chimie ouais mais finalement
vous choisissez la passion quoi partir
de 69 vous devenez comédien à plein
temps près de 2 3 ans de d'enseignement
j'ai tenté l'aventuré je veux dire et là
d'un côté je faisais des petits boulots
et de l'autre côté je continue à tenter
de mon aventure de comédien à vos
parents étaient très fâchés parce qu'il
s'était saigner aux quatre veines pour
vous et vous tient un peu tout ça en
l'air quoi ma mère était compréhensive
mon père comprenais pas mais j'avais le
soutien de mes frères qui ont à mes
frères eux me comprenait c'était risqué
de se lancer
c'est sûr que avec le recul j'ai été un
inconscient oui tout à fait vrai votre
premier film c'est quoi alors mon
premier film c'est celui qui m'a empêché
de partir au canada
c'est à dire que j'étais un peu
découragé en 69 de faire des efforts
comme ça pour jouer et ses théâtres et
tout et j'ai je pige pas un piège quand
je décide d'aller tout recommencer à
zéro au canada à montréal et
l'enseignement et le théâtre et huit
jours avant je rencontre jacques roset
qui cherchait quelqu'un pour son
téléfilm qui devenu a vu le cinéma il
qui est devenu du côté de rouette m'a
convaincu il m'a empêché de partir
ensuite grâce à jacques rozier donc l'un
des fils de pascal thomas rey pleure pas
la bouche pleine le chaud lapin la nuit
américaine doit donc soit plus fort et
même voyage et vous devenez une star
quoi je deviens quelqu'un qui est en
haut de l'affiché au cinéma oui
la célébrité est arrivé assez vite
finalement oui oui elle m'a permis de
revenir d'ailleurs au théâtre par la
grande porte
ouais du coup j'ai très vite alterner la
fin dès que j'ai pu alterner avec le
théâtre et en étant en tête d'affiché au
théâtre quelles ont été les réactions de
notre entourage quand vous êtes devenus
célèbres comme ça votre père par exemple
qui voulait pas du tout plus choyés
comédiens en parle c'est toujours pareil
il est évident que
les parents deviennent fier surtout ma
mère elle est elle-même présenté au
voisinage
à l'époque donc quelles étaient vos
relations avec les médias à ce que ça se
passait bien
vous n'êtes pas facile quand même à vous
trouvez moi je trouve ça moi je trouve
que non je trouve que je si je suis pas
facile c'est parce que je n'aime pas
qu'on se fout de ma gueule
j'ai gagné de l'argent à l'époque avec
tous ses films oh j'ai commencé en
gagner au fur et à mesure que le cerveau
fermeture qui est des films s'enchaînent
avec des rôles importants
j'avais le droit d'être payé un peu plus
mais je vais le dire un truc c'était
pour qu'elle n'a rien à voir avec
l'époque d'aujourd'hui c'était des
salaires beaucoup plus raisonnable est
ce que cette célébrité vous a amené des
aventures amoureuses des des rencontres
j'ai rencontré ma femme en 74 sur le
tournage du chaud lapin ouais des prêts
destinés comme non je ne la pas et
d'ailleurs je joue un personnage de
s'appeler williams dans ce film et j'ai
appelé mon premier fils william
alors avant de me marier bon bah oui
peut-être un peu mais et
et après que je me sois mariée bien sûr
ce n'est plus pareil
et il ya surtout que le sida en plus
c'est arrivé et je peux vous dire que ça
ça m'a calmé plus d'un quel était le
meilleur moment de cette époque là il ya
eu là ma rencontre avec jean françois
truffaut ça c'est extraordinaire parce
que je reçois un coup de téléphone
bonjour ici suzanne schiffman
l'assistante de françois truffaut et
françois truffaut voudrais vous voir oui
j'ai déjà et moi je suis le pape et je
voudrais bien savoir comment ils peuvent
connaître
elle me dit il a vu le film de jacques
rozier jeu ça m'étonnerait n'ai pas fait
une tournée il n'est pas il n'est pas
monté il n'est pas sorti et m'a dit il a
vu des rush vers des bouts d'essai là
c'est possible je me rends aux rues
robert estienne aux films du carrosse à
l'époque et en me disant il est en train
de voir un certain nombre de personnes
peut-être 40 50 pour un rôle et la une
du bonjour je rentre et au bout de trois
minutes j'ai compris que non c'était pas
en avance avec personne il était en
train de le vérifier j'étais pas
différent de ce qu'ils imaginaient grand
moment bah oui parce qu'au bout de deux
trois mille vies bon ben vous vous allez
à côté rencontré directeur de production
il va faire une proposition vous lui
direz ça vous va comme si j'étais en
état de discuter voilà et tout ça c'est
fait et un grand moment enfin que dont
je me rappellerai toujours c'est quand
louis de funès préparer la var c'est à
dire un an avant ouais j'ai eu j'ai eu
connaissance de ça donc je me suis payé
de culot et c'est la seule fois dans ma
vie que j'ai fait ça je me suis payé une
culot d'aller le voir dans sa loge un an
avant il était en train de tourner le
film précédent et je lui dis bonjour
bonjour de funès je m'appelle bernard
menez je ne sais pas si vous me
connaissez ils m'arrêtent tout de suite
si je vous connais très bien je vous ai
vus dans les films de pascal chaumeil
tous très bien je l'avais écouté je
voulais simplement vous dire que si vous
n'avez pas encore choisi le comédien qui
doit faire la flèche dans l'avare oui
j'aurai beaucoup beaucoup aimé les
bonnes idées et je m'apprêtais à partir
1 et marais team lycée fait d'y aller
voir le producteur et vous lui direz que
c'est vous pire moment de toute cette
époque
1 je me rappellerai toujours c'est que
j'avais consacré deux ans de ma vie à
jouer au théâtre
trois théâtres parisiens de tourner le
roi des cons d'après wolinski
oui et donc j'avais porté le projet
pendant deux ans depuis la création et
au moment de faire le film
le distributeur je crois trouvait que je
n'étais pas assez star et
il a exigé que ce soit quelqu'un d'autre
qui fasse le fait qu'il a fait francis
perrin oui
non mais c'est pas rien contre francis à
sa place j'aurais dit oui tout de suite
bien sûr j'ai simplement c'était s'était
d'abord pas justifiées au niveau de la
notoriété je pensais qu'on était où elle
était tif tiff au niveau cinéma en tout
cas et je pense surtout que gt gt le
personnage complètement dedans et que
c'était une erreur de casting
d'ailleurs pas une grosse erreur mais en
tout cas le film n'a pas beaucoup marché
c'est vrai alors vous êtes souvent
victime de railleries de moqueries car
vous avez fait des films excellents
évidemment on vient de me dire mais
aussi des grosses farces un petit pic
des nanars à la française parce que la
frisée aux lardons
je pense à mes maisons mais mes anciens
collègues style darricau louga la grue
et compagnie ou même lefebvre et c'est
vrai que quand vous avez beaucoup de
films d'ailleurs forcément pas que des
très bons films mais globalement je
trouve que j'ai un bon pourcentage
oui mais vous en souffrez de ça quand
même ça non je trouve ça très con way je
veux dire une fois j'avais fait une
émission de 2 de fogiel juste avant
l'émission j'étais j'attendais dans le
studio et y passer une petite bande
vouloir raconter ce que j'ai fait sur 50
films il n'avait plus les 4 5
les 400 que l'on pouvait me reprocher
mais il n'avait parlé que de ça ouais
c'était monstrueux comment est-ce que
terrible c'est quand vous attribue même
des films dans lesquels vous avez pas
jouer absolument mon curé chez les
nudistes j'ai jamais fait ça les gens
sont persuadés que vous êtes dedans mais
je non seulement je n'ai jamais je n'ai
jamais tourné deux films de cette sorte
là et bien sûr vous expliquer comment
ces méchancetés
non c'est un shoot annaba de garder des
films des films franchouillard en dix
ans il a fait ça et là peut-être c'est
ça du tout mais vos enfants n'ont
souffert de ça un peu ouais un peu parce
que eux à l'école les moqueries cesser
les parents qui leur transmettra donc
j'étais obligé d'essayer de protéger un
peu là tu assures alors voilà au milieu
des années 80 la comédie populaire à la
française se fait rare vous un peu plus
on vous trouve au théâtre on nous trouve
à la télévision et vous serez
progressivement redécouvert finalement à
la faveur d'une certaine nostalgie du
cinéma populaire charbon dix ans je le
sens je le cherche vraiment un
il ya eu en particulier cette fameuse
chanson jolie poupée maintien qui a fait
un tube énorme 1 million j'étais numéro
un au hit parade devant michael jackson
thriller devant cette semaine et il en
est mort oui c'est un peu plus tard dans
les années 90
pendant deux ans j'ai je me suis
retrouvé un peu comme angers dire en
tête de distribution de ce feuilleton
vivement lundi qui a été un très gros
succès aussi je vais le public et dont
j'étais très fier
en 2002
vous présenter aux législatives paris
15e sans étiquette vous dépenser
beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup de temps
beaucoup d'argent beaucoup d'argent je
dirais pas bon ça tournait autour de dix
mille euros c'est pas c'est pas énorme
mais pour un résultat assez faible oui
et non parce qu'en 2002 j'étais 4e sur
vingt candidats alors quand vous savez
que le premier s'était balladur soutenu
par le rpr et deuxième j'étais anne
hidalgo soutenue par le ps et que le
troisième a battu de quelques voix et
c'était le front national qui à l'époque
avait eu 20 s'il n'y avait pas eu ce
achètent et troisièmement je t'ai pas si
mal pour quelqu'un qui n'avait aucun
parti mais voulez vous lancer dans la
politique
je voulais même le faire avant et moi
j'ai des idées très précises qui à mon
sens je pourrai pour remettre le train
en marche
mais si il faut le vouloir il faut il
faut ne pas vouloir son intérêt
personnel et vouloir l'intérêt collectif
il ya beaucoup trop de salaire qui
échappe aux charges sociales dont
quelques-uns paye pour tout le monde
mais alors vous que vous deviez faire un
parti politique
j'étais prêt à ma parenté à un parti
plus tôt sans preuve voilà or
aujourd'hui bernard est ce que vous êtes
nostalgique de cette époque du chaud
lapin ne pleure pas la bouche pleine d
film de pascal thomas des films de
truffaut
je pense que j'ai eu la chance de de
connaître cette époque parce que je
pense et je suis bien content d'avoir
exercé mon métier à cette époque là
parce que
le le monde de cons dans lequel on est
aujourd'hui me convient beaucoup moins
alors si c'était à refaire tout ça
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil
j'ai fait la fine bouche sur le dernier
film de jean gabin on m'avait proposé
l'année sainte par le rôle de brialy et
quand j'ai lu le scénario je vais dire
ça c'est pas terrible alors ça ça n'a
pas trop plu aux pêcheurs et aux
distributeurs qui ont été voir ailleurs
et à l'époque vraiment la proposition
était ferme
j'aurais dû me dire c'est jean gabin
c'est gagné 2 darrieux j'aurais j'ai
fait un petit péché d'orgueil peut-être
le jour vous allez mourir qui se voulait
qu'on marque sur votre tombe comme
épitaphe
j'ai pas pensé mais de toute façon je
je voudrais me faire incinérer les
cendres je m'en fiche un peu de ce
qu'ils deviendront jamais way absolument
je pense je pense que on est de passage
un chéri on est des milliards et des
milliards de plus
quand vous regardez des milliards de dhs
étoiles de un plein est et où on est
vraiment une poussière ouais ça serait
beau de la fin au revoir c'est très
heureux de rallumer la lumière sont
ouverts n'a pas fait plaisir elle n'est
pas éteinte
merci les corrections de ne rien rater
de finale andy tube abonnez vous mettez
un pouce bleus